thank you for giving me this opportunity
to share we
key findings
original politics this book is about the
support that new democracies provide for
the democratization of other countries
consider for example that the iconic
Czechoslovak dissident vaclav havel
continued his activism even after
Czechoslovakia was free by supporting
the democratization struggles of
neighboring and faraway countries and he
did so both when he was an activist as
well as continued doing so when he was a
presence of the Czech Republic in the
picture here you see his several
expressions of his solidarity with three
opposition movements but there were of
course many others that he supported
massive covers of course not unique
among the activists and policymakers in
the Czech Republic nor is the Czech
Republic unique in central Eastern
Europe or among the other new
democracies that were born in the wake
of the third wave of democratization and
it is precisely this type of effort that
is the focus of my book in the book I
discussed how how proud multiple
activists expressed solidarity train
existence in terms of funding as well as
advocate on the
of other four Democratic activists
approach I also discuss how newly
democratic states provide diplomatic
support democracy of systems and
leverage leverage their membership in
various regional and global forums to
support the democratization of other
countries and in the book I tried to
answer four questions the first question
is why is it that some new democracies
are more active than others in
supporting the democratization of other
countries then I also asked why is it
that those countries choose as
recipients of particulars and the
countries over others I also look in the
question of why said those democracy
promoters prefer certain types of
support over others and finally I look
at the strengths and the mutations of
these democracy promoters by answering
these questions I look to take part in
three or other sets of debates in the
literature the first one is about the
emergence of a new class of democracy
promoters in those are new democracies
most of the literature and democracy
commotions focuses on the efforts of the
West those tend to be established
democracies and develop economies such
as the US the Nordic countries the UK
and even the EU but they really
overlooked or at least not
systematically exam
the efforts of some of the newest
democracies in the world today and
that's what I hope to do in this book I
also consider the effort that these new
democracy promoters as a special case of
revolutionary export because as you will
see in the rest of the stone they're
wrong democratic breakthroughs inform
their democracy promotion activities in
many many ways and i also see their
efforts is an example of the exercise of
soft power by regional actors such as
the new democracies in central eastern
europe that I study I also think about
these efforts as an example of diffusion
enterpreneurship and theorizing as a
mechanism underlying waves of regime
change most of the literature on
diffusion tends to focus on the
unfolding and outcome of diffusion
processes and it has tended to
understudy the agency of actors
especially ones that have adopted a
practice and then went on to promote it
further into other countries and again
this is the focus
so now allow me to turn to my key
findings and caveat them by saying that
my empirical focus is on the European
new democracies in the first two decades
after the collapse of communism in the
region what I have on this slide is a
table which describes the activism of of
the new Eastern European democracies in
supporting the democratization about
their countries and the important line
in this table is really the last where
you will see sort of a single score
depicting the level of activism of each
country and again what you can see is
that there is a significant variation in
the ways in which the various countries
supported an organization of others on
the one hand you on the one hand you
have some such as Bulgaria that have
invested very little in supporting with
amortisation about their countries on
the other hand you have countries such
as the Czech Republic Slovakia who have
been quite active in supporting the
democratic circles of other countries
usually
work so that obviously poses a question
of how can we explain this variation why
said that some countries such as the
Czech Republic Poland and Slovakia why
have been why have they been more active
than other countries like the area
pretended to be
I answered this question in two ways I
look at why is it that some civil
society actors or NGOs have been more
active but also I have some states been
more active and I find that Eastern
European democracy promotion began with
the activities and international
solidarity of some of the activists who
organized the domestic breakthroughs in
these countries so a number of these
activists continue to support the
democratization and democratic
consolidation of their own country but
they also supported the transnational
diffusion of democracy and aided a
number of other countries this activist
usually had ties to other pro-democracy
activists abroad and it was through the
interactions along those size that they
perceived a duty and obligation of our
responsibility to support the
democratization struggles
it's a prop in here duty obligation and
responsibility are words that they said
they themselves used to describe the
perceptions of the motivations for their
activism so a number of these activists
and NGOs that they worked for with
Western support and encouragement began
to provide technical and moral support
to other countries usually shortly after
that they're on Democratic great group
what's interesting however is that over
time some of the NGOs in which those
activists were embedded began to
increasingly use democracy promotion is
a way of organization of survival and
expansion those activists realized that
they have in their own words expertise
to sell and so they use the embeddedness
in a variety of donor networks to again
provide funding for their own
organizations and to keep the lights on
in other words we see that over time
these organizational concerns came to
displace the normative drivers behind
much but no not all of the International
democracy promotion work in each of
these
in addition to supporting the
transnational diffusion of democracy a
number of these activists and NGOs
applicated that their own government
support the democratization of other
countries as well and these NGOs
organized advocacy campaigns and usually
time those domains at various critical
junctures in the foreign policy history
of their own sometimes did so
immediately after a round domestic
breakthrough others chose to wait until
their country entered the eor NATO and
they also benefited from the support and
receptiveness of some of their former
opposition allies who had entered
politics and we're eager to get there to
get the input of their civic colleagues
and implement policies based on it
however what I found is that it is only
in the cases where these activists
represented strong contingents for large
in United movements able to articulate
resonant arguments that their campaigns
were successful and that their states
embedded democracy promotion and
therefore
now let me illustrate that with the
example of a somewhat surprising
democracy promoter Somalia a small
country and a relatively new state of
which you would be surprised to see them
they kind of acted the part foreign
policy that democracy promotion and
kills yet as you saw on the table on the
previous slide so backe is among the
most active promoters so how did that
begin so lucky I became independent with
the distribution of Czechoslovakia 93
and shortly after that the democratic
transition of the country became
arrested by their leads that organized
the Independence of the country so the
political position in the country and
civil society used the 1998
parliamentary elections as an
opportunity that you organize a
Democratic breakthrough and push the
country in a decidedly Democratic
direction and it was this campaign that
gave the beginning of what would later
become known as the wave of the collar
or electoral revolutions in the region
and you saw such revolutions in
countries such as gracious serbia
georgia chemist on ukraine and so on so
these activists immediately recognized
that in their campaign they have a
useful model for defeating illiberal
rulers for raining over hybrid or
electrical democracies and that was a
realization that was shared by a number
of their donors and fellow activists
abroad and so in the year after the
break room the Freedom House paid for a
seminar that allowed us some of the key
Slovak organizers to share the lessons
they had learned in their
democratization campaign with brother ma
Christie activists from countries such
as gracious Serbia Russia Ukraine and
Belarus that initial exchange turned
into long-term cooperation and was
followed by a number of other similar
exchanges and so eventually know in
about five or six years there were as
many as a dozen and a half NGOs who were
consistently in a sustained manner
providing democracy support the firm
another interesting fact is that at the
very beginning a number of those NGOs
interested in support
the democratization of neighboring
Serbia also decided to approach their
state and insists that the Slavic states
similarly suppose or the derivatization
of Serbia they were successful in
convincing their foreign policy makers
namely the foreign minister as well as
the ambassador to Saudi ambassador in
Serbia then just as democracy was an
antidote to nationalist liberalism in
Slovakia so it could solve many of the
problems that at the time seemed to be
blaming the western province and so
democracy promotion they argued is a way
personal back yet to stabilize its
neighbourhood make it a peaceful
prosperous place they were successful as
I said because there was a number of
them that and they were worked together
and managed to propose to their foreign
policy makers compelling answers to
problems that at the time seemed
irrelevant yet the slovak foreign policy
makers had not figured out like to
address them but they think again what's
interesting about this llama case is
that you have quite an unexpected
democracy promotion and again I see that
as a result of the efforts the civic
pride morrissey activists in that
country again what's interesting also is
that their continued vigilance and
advocacy to the state allowed that
democracy promotion to continue at the
state level even when power turned over
to the previous to the successes of the
previous illiberal regime and so even
under that set of beliefs democracy
promotion continued because civil
society continues to actively
hard-working which again to me speaks to
the importance of activists and their
advocacy for active state policy for his
support of democracy abroad now allow me
to turn your attention to another
variation which I discovered and I'd
like to explain and that is the
variation in the recipients of these
living Rypien democracy promotion so
what you see this table is again the
Eastern European democracy promoters as
well as a range of their priority
recipients the countries with two stars
are what each of the donors considered
to be a parent a recipient whereas the
country's the recipients marked with one
star were some of the other recipients
that received support from the Eastern
Europe
countries and again as you see there is
quite some variation in those recipients
so of course an interesting question is
how can it be explained I found that at
the level of state efforts there was
some democracy promotion idealism and
they were a number of politicians who
paid principle attention to the
democratization struggle in other
countries but if the efforts that
resulted from these principles efforts
have been rather ad hoc and episodic on
the other hand democracy has tended to
be understood in center and Eastern
Europe as an improved domestic order and
both Civic and political elites in those
newly democratic countries expected
similar improvements in other countries
where those other countries to become
democratic and so many of the arguments
that the Civic advocates of democracy
promotion head with their state
counterparts about why their country
should be supporting democratization of
a broad revolved not only about the
mortal concerns the democracy promotion
addressed but primarily around the
geostrategic and general foreign policy
challenges the democracy promotion for
the dress and so in most of these
Eastern you
ian country's democracy promotion became
embedded as a foreign policy as a means
to creating a more favorable
international environment let me
illustrate this argument with another
case study this time of quality
important democracy promotion became a
geopolitical strategy for creating
reliable partners in the country's near
abroad as well as for deterring Russian
aggression you have to remember that
Russia had for centuries threatened
Polish independence and also that for
poems the transition to market democracy
was bought the sternal away from
communism at the domestic order as well
as a struggle in Soviet imperialism as a
way of regaining the sovereignty of the
Polish nation state and so it was this
dual purpose of democracy that informed
the democracy promotion strategy of the
partition needs today pollen has tended
to support the democratization of its
mutual neighbors with Russia so those
are countries such as Ukraine and
Belarus for those who Georgian google
and it has pollen has tended to believe
that were those countries democratic
they will also choose their own
sovereignty and would then stay away
from the Russian sphere of influence
therefore containing the temptation of
Russia to research as an imperial power
of the European continent
so again I think what's interesting here
is that the rationale that was fleshed
out with the product of the conversation
between civil society and the state but
also that at the state level the
manifestation that it had was a very
security oriented logic that drove the
everyday democracy promotion efforts of
the bar state another important question
that they look to answer is what shaped
it's the democracy promotion efforts of
these the new European states actually
click and I found that they most of them
tended to selectively draw their own
transition experience they thought about
their own democratic break Bruce and
periods of democratic consolidation as
an experiment in which they learned many
lessons about what works but also about
what did not work and they thought about
those lessons as recipes where those are
of steps to follow to defeat
authoritarians and also to achieve
particular form objectives so they look
to share those recipes with other superb
and out of all the recipes that they
thought they had most of the Eastern
European democracy promoters tried to
look for ones that fit the needs of
their recipients and so that's an
interesting distinction between these
emerging democracy promoters and some of
the Western democracy promoters and
their efforts
the way that the perfect temperature
describes them so if you look at the way
that democracy promotion talk literature
talks about efforts of the West or the
you you would often find descriptions of
Western democracy promoters as thinking
back to their own domestic models of
democracy and thinking of their
constituent elements in looking to
replicate those elements abroad these
tenure appearing countries are doing
something very similar except instead of
thinking in institutional terms they
look for reform processes that they can
export and so that has produced a
difference in that the Western countries
tend to export models of democracy while
Eastern European countries have tended
to export models of democratization let
me